Bloomberg politics writer William leitch
wrote this and I liked it Tom quote
people love football but they hate the
NFL this is Roger Goodell legacy
Bloomberg 70 v williams cover sports for
us and joins us now on set evidence is
true is Roger Goodell ruining football
for America I don't think he's ruining
it necessarily but I think wills exactly
right people love to hate the
Commissioner they love to hate the
shield they hate the big business that
the NFL is but as you said you're
excited about the opener people are
gonna watch tonight they're gonna watch
on Sundays for the next 17 weeks it's
Goodell in danger of losing his job I
don't think so no and the reason is
because people love his product Goodell
works for the owners he's essentially a
hero and fungal deflate he bungled it
without question and everybody came out
with you poorly after deflategate Tom
Brady and the Patriots right so we saw
yesterday oven the Apple rollout and all
that they featured major league baseball
is is TV in the NFL still about that
Sunday moment or that thursday night
football moment or can they be more
creative like we see another sports
absolutely it's about it's about the
live content and they're starting to be
a little more creative we saw earlier
this week they launched a service where
for a hundred dollars a season you can
watch any game live as soon as it's over
and the question is I'm lost on yeah so
help me exactly its mean it's free
revenue right it's a even if twenty
people sign up that's money that they
that they wouldn't have had otherwise
but yeah the NFL relative to Major
League Baseball has a much more buttoned
up TV approach and I think you'll see
that kind of starting to loosen in the
next couple years of some of these
contracts come up and and they start
looking at digital and another
opportunity it's a pete rozelle age
still there he used to be nuts about
like everybody ended matching tape and
matching shoes and it was very centrally
commanded it is absolutely still
centrally commanded I mean you see every
Sunday you see guys that are fine
because the towel you're on color or
it's too long or one of their Sox's on
me and I got all I got go back to the
cheating just like this ESPN story
everybody's talking about it we're
talking about literally somebody from
the pats team going into the opponent's
locker room and swiping play sheet that
story had 90 sources 90s
so doesn't somebody have to go I mean
nobody's responsible for this yes our
stories of General Counsel's stamping on
tapes surveillance video showing the
patched alleged a large part of that
ESPN story from a couple days ago was
essentially alleging that a lot of the
Tom Brady punishment flake ate was kind
of left over from from spy game eight
seconds who's gonna win the Super Bowl
oh man y'all there we go everybody come
back